Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 19 in my 0 to 100 mil flipping
series. Today we're starting at about
31.3 mil. Got some pretty decent
progress last episode, so we're probably
going to continue on with some of the
similar items. Probably going to do the
al of gods again. Might do some more
darkness sets, stuff like that. See
where we can go from here. I'm actually
going to try out the tome of fire as
well. Uh so we'll see how that goes. And
yeah, let's get started. So, we're just
checking the margin on the ale of the
gods because it's been a couple days
since I've actually flipped this item.
Uh, so we bought it for 6.4 mil and
we'll see what we can sell it for. Not
that much. Put in for 5700 and see what
we sell it for. 6 mil. Uh, so that's
pretty good. 400k margins pretty decent.
Uh, so we'll definitely go ahead and buy
some of these. I don't really know if
we're going to bother getting anything
else. We might just buy five of these
and call it quits for today. Yeah. Yeah.
So, I think we're just going to put an
offer in for I guess five of these. And
I'll just come back tomorrow.
Okay. So, we are back and this actually
worked quite well. We ended up buying
them all for 6,100k each instead of 6
mil. But still, we made a serious amount
of profit on this. I think we got 2.5
mil in profit off this item.
Um, because we sold three of them for an
700k profit, I guess. Yeah. and two of
them for a 200k profit that given us
about 2500k in profit. I mean minus we
did check it so minus another 400. So we
made probably 2 mil off the flip a
little bit more. So that's quite good.
I'm definitely going to try these again.
So I did check the margin and it wasn't
very good. But that being said, um I
think I'm just going to put an offer in
for 6 mil because it's still quite a bit
lower than I bought them for in the
past. Uh supposed to leave this in and
hopefully by the time we're ready to
sell them, they have changed prices.
Unfortunately, uh the ale of the gods
did not really rise up at all. So, I
pretty much just sold them for
100k profit on three of them and just
zero. Broke even on the other two. Uh
so, I mean 300k is 300k. It's not too
bad, but um not nearly as good as the
last flip unfortunately. So, we might
consider a different item going forward
now. So, I think we're actually going to
try the tome of fire. Um, it's a pretty
new item now. We bought it for 790K and
we're going to sell it for
700K. So, that's a 90k profit on that.
That's quite good. There's a lot of
these coming into the game right now.
Um, couple hundred traded every hour.
So, I mean, I'll hit the limit for it,
but we'll see how many we can actually
buy of these. And yeah, if we buy like
30 or 40 of them, I think is what we can
afford, we could actually make a good
amount of profit. It's a little bit
risky, though, so we'll have to see how
it goes. Um, but we'll put an offer in
for 40 and we'll come back when we've
sold some of them. Oh my god, I just
lost a ton of money. H, we can see my
history here. I kind of freaked out and
started selling them. So, we bought 32
to fire for 22 mil and then we sold a
couple of them for like a bit of a
profit, then another nine for a tiny bit
of profit, but then they just tanked it.
So, we ended up having to sell the last
20 for like 500k. We lost so much,
unfortunately.
In total, I think we lost 3.6 mil, which
is kind of sucky.
Probably not going to do this item ever
again. So, I mean, that's the risk of
flipping new items. They are pretty
volatile in price.
Oh well, let's continue on and see if we
can at least break even this episode.
Okay, so next up is going to be the
Elder Chaos Top. I think has about a 40k
margin and it's only about a 300k item,
so it's pretty decent. Um, there's
couple hundred of these traded every
day, so they buy decently quickly. Uh,
so put an offer in for 20 and just leave
it at that. Next up, we're going to do
the Hood of Darkness. We're back to the
Darkness set because they never screwed
us over this badly. Um, so the margin's
still 40 or 50 and we'll buy 20. And uh,
yeah, hopefully that'll do better than
the freaking tomb.
Next up, we're just checking the Robe of
Darkness. Uh, so we bought it for 600k
and we're going to sell it for
500k. That's pretty decent, actually.
That's 100k profit on each one.
Definitely going to do these. Put an
offer in for 20 of them, I'm pretty
sure, again. And uh, put an offer. Well,
put them in for 501k.
A little bit of a dick, but um, still
fair game.
And lastly, we are checking the robe of
darkness again. Um, just going to go
back to the darkness set because it has
actually worked so well for us in the
past. Need to redeem some of our money.
Uh, so this has a 60k margin on it,
which is pretty nice. Still very good
margin on these darkness items. Uh, so
we'll put an offer in for 20 of these
and yeah, we'll come back when we've
sold some of the stuff. Okay, we're back
and we did pretty decent on this flip.
Definitely better than the last one. Um,
the Elder Chaos Hood and the Hood of
Darknesses. We got 20 and sold 20, which
is nice. And we also on both of those
got a 17k margin on each one. So for
each 20 items, we got 340k in profit.
And uh the
uh robe top of darkness, sorry. Uh we
got a 100k margin on it, which is great.
And we got 10 of those, giving us a
clean 1 mil in profit. And the robe
bottom of darknesses, we are still
selling, but still getting about a 60k
margin on those as well. Uh, so that's
pretty good. We actually got about 1.6
mil in profit. Uh, so we're kind of
getting back up there. So I think we're
going to do the rogue top of darknesses
because they worked quite well last
time. Um, so it's about a 50 60k margin
on it. So we'll put an offer in for 20
and leave that for a while. So we're
just kind of looking through the master
clue scroll items and we kind of
stumbled upon this bucket helm gold.
Kind of just wanted to put a random
offer in. It's definitely not 126 mil.
I've checked the RS Buddy price. It's
closer to 20 mil, but uh still I have
zero idea what the price is.
Let's maybe use the rest of our money
for it and just see if we can buy it
with this 17 mil we have in the
inventory. If we do, we could make I
don't know five or six mil if we get
lucky. Uh if not, we'll probably just
not buy it, which is fine. And yeah,
we'll come back when um most likely
we've sold uh the rope tops. Well, this
is awkward. Our membership actually
expired. Uh whoops. Uh but we did sell
the road bottoms um for a let's see 61k
profit and we got 18 of those giving us
over a million profit close to 1100k so
very good on that as well. Uh,
unfortunately we do have to buy a bond
because it just expired apparently. So,
we'll go buy that. And we didn't get the
bucket helm unfortunately. Not super
surprised by that, but still you could
kind of always dream. But, um, we're at
32.1 mil again. Pretty close to where we
started at. Um, but we have to go buy
the bond. And, yeah, we'll come back
when we have a new item. Okay. So, the
Ae of the Gods has a 400k profit on it
again. So, I think we're going to do it
again. It's down to about 5.5 mil now.
Uh, which is quite a bit lower, but it
still has a very good margin on it. So,
we'll probably still do this. Just going
to use the rest of our money. That was a
very expensive bond. It was almost 4
mil. It was closer to. Unfortunately,
we're down to about 28 mil now. But,
we'll put an offer in for five of these
ale of the gods. And come back when they
have sold. Okay, so we're back. And
while we did lose a bunch of money this
episode on the stupid tome of fires, we
are making it back with these ale of the
gods, which is awesome. Uh we did end up
bumping them up to about 5600 each. So
in total we spent 28 mil on buying them
and we sold them for 29.1 mil giving us
over 1 mil in profit which is awesome.
We're getting pretty close to where we
started the episode at which if we can
get anywhere back even to that'll be
awesome. I mean cuz we bought the bond
and we lost like 4 mil. So if we can
break even I'll be very happy.
And we're just going to put another
offer in. I mean, it's just working so
well. We might as well stick with it for
a bit longer. Put an offer in for 5,500k
and we'll come back if we buy some of
these. Okay, we are back and we have
sold all of the ale of the gods. They
actually flipped quite quickly. Uh, we
got a 200k margin each one and five of
those gives us another 1 mil in profit.
So, we're pretty much back to where we
started and unfortunately I think that's
where I'm going to end the episode. I
mean, we renewed our bond, which was 3.5
mil, I think, for that. Very expensive.
Um, we came back from that massive loss
at the beginning. I mean, without those
two, we would have made like 8 mil in
profit this episode, but unfortunately
wasn't meant to be. But, hope you guys
enjoyed still, and I will see you guys
in episode 20.
[Music]